how many times did fox news cover
benghazi
and then once hillary clinton was out
but you're never defending someone
that's
indefensible people died yeah you're
talking about lives how many times did
they talk about hillary's emails in
benghazi
because it
the email ended up being true the emails
of hillary clinton that she trashed them
and that was that was true just so you
know
the 33 000 emails that's an accurate
story that's not a
dossier the russia is a fake news okay
that is fake news
the story about hunter biden on his
laptop is true news that is not fake
those text messages are
real right that's not like a fake thing
that so fake stories
they market the hell out of it true
stories they kind of stay away from it
there's a little bit of hypocrisy there
by the way
again i'm telling you guys if there's
ever been a time
for a media platform to just come out
and tell both sides of the stories where
the audience can make a decision for
themselves
yeah it's now today is the time to do it
all the time yeah give both sides of the
story the america is
craving common sense they're just
looking for that by the way did you guys
see the story over the weekend
and i know this guy very well personally
his name is christopher sein he was an
anchor in alabama okay in birmingham he
was the 10 o'clock anchor and he's from
alabama he played football at alabama
i knew him because he used to work at
abc in phoenix great guy unbelievable
family man three kids
he was the guy that broke the story of
loretta lynch on the tarmac at sky
harbor airport 45
2016. okay and that bill clinton got out
of his plane in 112 degree heat
walked over and spent 20 minutes in the
plane with loretta lynch when they were
investigating hillary and the email
server
okay he received tons of death threats
tons of credible death threats because
he wrote a book about it
and when he went on the publicity tour
they were coming together threats were
real
and he died seriously he you hear about
this guy or the tournament
he died he's not he's dead okay and
they're saying he committed suicide
that's the part of the story which makes
no
sense if anybody knows him it makes no
sense it's almost physically impossible
to convince somebody that knows him
that he committed suicide the guy loved
life he loved his family more than you
can imagine he was yucking it up with
his co-workers on friday night
talking about what they were going to do
that weekend the next morning he's dead
so i don't know that's all i got but he
was a great guy
rest in peace great family all around
the clintons if you say something
a lot of people that come inside as if
the moment you say something about
you're like
my life's not worth it let me take my
own life it's either that
or it's something else that's the
speculation part
look you ever you ever had a friend in
school
or a colleague or something where every
time somebody got close to that person
either their life got worse or their
business got worse
after about a few years you have to sit
there and say dude does this guy
really want the best for me or not
there's something going on there like
for example let's just say
you and i start you've never hung out
with me before okay we start hanging out
together
next thing i know you're gaining 30
pounds
next thing i know your savings depleted
next thing i know you picked up a lot of
bad habits next thing i know you got a
couple duis you're getting arrested
you're doing stupid things that happen
into your life
next thing i know you're creating a lot
of new enemies that you never had before
me and then same story here same story
there same story with like
45 people there's something going on
over there
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye